hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to do Falls the game where
the players of this game know about as
much about sports as I do which is not a
lot it's a physics based soccer game so
watch out the FIFA's and soccer and
footballs of the world little Boosh
okay I think I think I'm Team Red and
you click on what moves around like a
dick oh that was an epic pass over to
this guy hang on okay alright this
problem with physics can you get up you
dick ah hey you missed it what no
blanket blanket wow I am so sorry my
team I have failed you and now you're
doing celebratory push-ups of sadness
what are you laughing at me
stop it oh my god you can't be kidding
me come here you [ __ ] I kicked it yeah
I think I'm supposed to get over there
oh can we not all mob and fall over each
other right about now that would be
ideal if we didn't watch match over why
are we standing like this why are we do
this I think the field is too wide we
need to narrow it up a little bit let's
go again this should make it easier for
me I'm coming for you [ __ ] I kicked it
high actually
oh no oh no no no no no where's the guy
over there ah here we go
it's your time to shine bro him get out
of his way you junkie ball ass piece of
ass okay stop standing around like a
loser and yeah hug that guy dance with
them dance real good okay no you tried
to break dance and you failed can we
have some competence on our team yeah
good defense but you're not supposed to
use your hands I don't think
hahahahahaha it's just impossible
the computer is far better than I am now
that the computer is that good based on
what I'm looking at okay okay all right
okay all right okay all right oh okay
this is how we're gonna do and then they
laugh that goofy laugh Mike okay alright
then I guess nobody wins in this game
all right let's we need to change it up
I still think it's unfair this field is
far too long that is better all right
let's go for it man let's go come on
bring it I'm a king of football soccer
get up get up get up get up get up you
dick oh don't hug and hump each other
this is not the time for that get up get
up get up get up okay nice ass but not
the time for that
boom what an epic kick for the war over
there come on stop watching from the
sidelines and do something maybe the
problem is something else let's see the
gate is now wide enough ah balls too
small and there aren't enough of them
that's what it needs to be let's see how
this fares against us Barsky Bert okay
how can you how can you lose this too
many okay you kicked a little early
there come on don't fall on your
teammate you douche stop get to the ball
you can't even get to the ball you're
pathetic
Wow I didn't even see that one
maybe you'll flail a ball into their
goal you stupid douches try again
hello on bring it [ __ ] huh yeah
alright you're facing the wrong way okay
nevermind you you had a moment of
celebration there and then you just
decide to do not win No do something
anything stop dancing you're all just
dancing why why are you dancing okay you
need more people
we need more balls we need bigger balls
and we need it to be even closer
together yeah let's try that one oh my
god my computer's lagging kick it all
you gotta do is kick it just a little
bit come on why oh oh no something has
gone horribly awry my computer can't
handle the intense physical situation of
this Oh
this match is incredible yeah we scored
I think go again go again my friends
we're gonna win this one in our giant
wiggling pile of man-meat which is the
biggest part of it yeah we got again
we're doing great we're doing great guys
it's gotta keep kicking and push it
until it gets in I see it right there
come on
ow
what are you doing you're falling over
each other like no you can't lose this
for me I've set it up oh ok crashed the
game ok so I seem to have made it unfair
for myself before so we're just gonna do
this one-on-one because oh I know this
was gonna turn into something like that
excuse me I don't have any time for that
I have to get to the ball
oh that's what that button does ok he's
just gonna fall over himself and that
gives you the opportunity to okay
alright that's that's good too
can you can you know go okay did you
know ho please come on just get to the
ball oh just get to the ball we only
have to score
oh really well okay you're holding hands
now that's delightful and beautiful but
in a way we don't oh it's stuck under
the wall come on no don't laugh this is
no time for that oh close was close okay
this game is officially unwinnable and
no one can possibly beat it okay there
was this other game mode that I found
called click ass which is where you go
[Laughter]
slightly wrong just watching it being
them in the head
I don't know why I just love it seeing
I'm getting beaned in the face oh he
bonk
are you way in the distance you right
there okay in the right there
oh he's a tough one since I can't get
funk this is slightly very slightly
rewarding here alright I think I've had
my fun and I think you guys have a good
idea what this game is all about this
has been goofball goofball goofball is
enabled and it's kind of fun there's not
a lot to it so I don't know if it's
exactly worth the price it's actually
six bucks which is kind of steep for a
game that only offers this but it's
actually pretty fun and I imagine that
when I get to play it with someone else
hopefully Bob I would love to because it
has local network and internet play so I
want to do that so anyway thank you all
so much for watching click the
annotation for more videos that I've
done and as always I will see you in the
next video
[Music]